[musique]
Renault Vandru Becc, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Bien,
Renault Van Rimbec, comme vous l'avez
dit, euh j'ai été juge d'instruction une
bonne partie de de ma vie. J'ai
notamment travaillé 20 ans euh au pôle
financier en tant que juge instruction
spécialisée.
J'ai fini doyen étant le plus vieux dans
la fonction. Donc, aucun mérite et j'ai
pris ma retraite il y a 3 ans.
Vous écrivez maintenant, vous faites des
enquêtes pour vous ?
Quand j'ai arrêté, j'ai arrêté.
d'un coup ça vous a pas manqué.
J'ai eu peur que ça me manque
mais une fois que j'ai arrêté, je vais
vous dire, j'avais tellement euh j'avais
beaucoup de gros dossiers et puis j'ai
voulu absolument les terminer avant de
partir. Euh que sans m'en rendre compte,
j'avais une pression dans mon petit
cerveau très très forte que le jour où
j'ai arrêté,
c'est comme un grand moment de de
respiration. Alors, je pense que ça
arrive à beaucoup de retraités.
Et je veux vous dire que ça fait du
bien. Voilà. Alors depuis j'ai écrit,
c'est vrai que j'ai pas complètement
coupé non plus puisque j'ai écrit deux
livres.
Euh pourquoi pourquoi j'ai écrit ? Euh
j'ai un ami que j'ai perdu
euh l'année dernière [grognement]
et à son âme.
Oui.
Qui était à la fois avec qui j'ai
travaillé notamment dans la Ferelf quand
il était au parquet, il était procureur,
il était vice-procureur. Et j'étais
jinstruction a vraiment travaillé la
main dans la main.
il a toujours été très loyal avec moi et
quand quand j'ai pris ma retraite, il
m'a dit "Renault, faut que tu écrives
d'abord, tu as vécu des gros dossiers et
une période de transition où le pouvoir
politique a essayé d'entraver d'ailleurs
parfois réussi entraver le travail des
juges d'instruction. Aujourd'hui, le
rapport de force a beaucoup changé. Les
juges sont libres de faire ce qu'ils
veulent. Faut que tu racontes cette
période parce que me dit-il, il était
historien aussi. il avait une double
casquette et il me dit "Les historiens,
ils ont besoin de témoins directs. Il y
a des gens qui racontent ce que d'autres
ont fait mais tu as un témoin direct."
Donc ce témoignage là faut le faire.
Donc c'était mon premier livre. Et puis
il me dit "N'oublie pas euh la dimension
internationale,
les difficultés que tu as rencontré dans
les enquêtes sur les offshore
et ça a été c'est mon deuxème mon
deuxième livre que j'ai consacré à ce
thème."
Donc nous on a décidé de vous faire
venir parce que c'est un sujet qui nous
passionne. C'est un sujet qui nous
passionne parce que ça a des des
implications, des intrications avec la
vie réelle des gens. Sauf que les gens
ne s'en rendent pas bien compte que
l'évasion fiscale, les montages
financiers infiniés, c'est eux qui paye.
C'est le service public qui paye. C'est
les infirmières qui payent, c'est les
hôpitaux qui payent, c'est les pompiers
qui payent, c'est les trous sur la route
qui payent, c'est les impôts.
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner
comme une échelle ou comme une
Ouais. comme la dimension de ça, ça
représente combien et après on va
rentrer plus dans le détail sur comment
c'est fait, par qui c'est fait, est-ce
qu'il y a une population prédisposée à
Est-ce que c'est plus concentré dans un
secteur 2 ? H
à vous la parole.
Euh les chiffres,
moi je les connais pas. Il y a des
économistes euh Zukman, Gabriel Zuckman
qui est un économiste réputé qui a
avancé le chiffre de 8700 milliards
d'euros dollars. J'avoue que je fais pas
la différence. D'autres avancent des
chiffres plus importants. C'est
colossal. Alors pas à l'échelle
française évidemment, à l'échelle de la
planète. Ça veut dire qu'il y a des
milliers Oui. Des milliers de milliards,
je sais pas comment on dit ça. Des
trillions des billions je sais rien.
Comment ?
Un billion.
Un billion en anglais peut-être. Non,
c'est un trion alors en français, il me
semble. Bon, c'est des sommes colossales
euh qui sont à l'abri dans les paradis
fiscaux et qui à minima correspondent à
de l'argent caché à l'abri du fil.
C'est-à-dire ceux qui ont cet argent ne
payent pas d'impôts ou très peu. Et
comme vous l'avez justement dit, euh les
c'est c'est un manque à gagner énorme
pour les États qui ont aujourd'hui qui
ont qui quand même des
parler du rapport entre l'économique et
le politique, mais on voit bien
aujourd'hui que les États prennent la
main quelque part et ont face à eux
d'immenses défis. Vous avez parlé des
hôpitaux mais on pourrait parler aussi
du financement de la
transition.
la transition climatique, vous voyez que
on arrive à lire dans nos pensées
réciproques, ça me rassure. Euh donc, il
y a des sommes énormes dont les
collectiv dont l'acte quand je dis
l'État pour moi c'est la collectivité à
besoin et dont elle est privée. Donc
résultat et ben ça fait porter toute la
charge sur ceux qui ne fraudent pas,
ceux qui ne peuvent pas frotter, ceux
qui ont pas une dimension internationale
et qui eux vont s'acquitter de l'impôt
et payer des charges et cetera. Donc ils
vont payer cette qui vont supporter seul
cette charge. Et ça je trouve que
aujourd'hui alors que les États ont des
besoins énormes,
qu'ils accumulent des déficits, qu'ils
sont très endettés, tout le paradoxe de
toute cette histoire que j'ai découverte
petit à petit, c'est de constater qu'il
y avait une masse d'argent à leur porte,
parfois un peu plus loin, on est
d'accord, mais auquel il ne touchait
pas. On ne touchait pas.
Donc je pense qu'un jour parce je suis
pas je suis pas un pessimiste de nature
je pense qu'un jour quand ils seront
vraiment acculés les États se
réveilleront et feront ma main basse non
pas sur la ville mais sur ces fonds qui
sont qui sont fraudés
les répercussions.
On a déjà vu les répercussions.
Comment on fait pour tracer ces flux
financiers ? Comment on les repère ?
C'est des insiders ? C'est des lanceurs
d'alerte ?
C'est comment on fait pour les traquer ?
Alors à mon niveau parce que moi je
parle en fait j'ai fait un constat
pendant pendant 20 ans. C'estàd j'ai au
début j'étais bécien, je comprenais rien
à ces circuits. Euh au bout de 20 ans,
j'ai commencé quand même à comprendre un
petit peu comment ça marchait, la
mécanique, comment comment tout ça était
était organisé. Et c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça que vous parliez du livre tout à
l'heure, mais cette expérience en
quelque sorte qui s'est soldé par
quelques succès mais aussi par des
échecs comme toute expérience, j'ai
voulu la faire partager au plus grand
nombre en leur disant
"Vous avez tous entendu parler des
offshore, des paradis fiscaux et cetera.
Moi, je vais vous donner les clés, voilà
comment ça marche concrètement pour vous
expliquer." Je je suis au stade du
constat. Ce constat, je l'ai fait.
Et le but aujourd'hui, c'est la
transmission, la prise de conscience.
Voilà, c'est ça mon c'est ça ma démarche
fondamentale en essayant d'expliquer le
plus simplement possible des mécanismes
qui paraissent vu l'extérieur
extrêmement complexes mais qui nous
concerne parce que encore une fois c'est
de l'argent fraudé, c'est des recettes
en moins pour la collectivité que nous
allons supporter et que nous supports.
Il y a pas que ça, il y a aussi des
trafiquants de drogue.
On parle des oligarques aujourd'hui. Il
y a des oligarques, on veut geler les
avoir des oligarques. Très bien, mais
allez-y, identifiez-les. Et là, on va
commencer à et là, ça va être le début
de la galère. C'està-dire que comment on
peut identifier ces circuits pour
répondre à votre question ? C'est
extrêmement compliqué. Moi, j'ai mis des
années dans les dossiers à à
reconstituer ou à tenter de reconstituer
des circuits et parfois, je n'y suis pas
arrivé. Pourquoi ? Parce que quelqu'un
qui cache 100 millions 100 millions de
dollars qu'il a eu d'une façon
totalement illégale, une personne
corrompue, un trafiquant de drogue ou
autre,
il va utiliser des masques dans les soci
dans des dans des dans les paradis
fiscaux. C'estàd que il n'aura rien à
son nom.
Il va ouvrir des comptes un peu partout
sur la planète à travers tout un réseau
de ce qu'on appelle de sociétés offshore
qui ne sont que des sociétés bidon, des
sociétés écran que vous achetez au
Bahamas clé en main ou à Panama
[raclement de gorge] ou ou aux îles
vierges britanniques et avec tout cet
échevaux, il va multiplier les comptes,
les masques. Et ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre, c'est que quand quand je
travaillais sur un sur des réseaux, par
exemple, la fraude carbone qui a été une
fraude énorme,
on part d'un compte qu'on l'identifie.
Alors faut déjà faut déjà l'identifier
au départ et puis après faut
reconstituer toute cette chaîne
de flux, tout ce tout ce caneva qui a
été monté. Mais moi à chaque fois, il me
faut il me faut du temps. C'està-dire
que si j'ai un compte un premier compte
en Suisse, euh il faut que je fasse une
demande, il faut que le juge accepte de
la traiter, il faut rentrer dans un
cadre légal et puis les personnes visées
vont pouvoir contester ma mesure dans en
Suisse même ou au Luxembourg ou
Linchenstein, c'est pareil. Donc ça va
prendre du temps. Donc j'aurai un
premier compte au bout de 6 mois, 1 an,
18 mois. Et puis là, je vais
m'apercevoir que l'argent ben il est
parti à Singapour.
Et là, à Singapour, bah je vais envoyer
une demande un an et demi plus tard.
J'ai déjà 1 an et demi dans la vue dans
mon dans mon enquête. Et à Singapour, je
dire ah voilà, il y a de l'argent qui
est parti de Suisse sur une société
offshore, une société panaméne à
Singapour.
Qui est le bénéficiaire de cette société
et qui est devenu cet argent ?
Et là, on va me répondre au bout de 6
mois, un an, bah c'est parti sur un
autre compte dans la même banque de
Singapour.
Il donne le montant ou pas ?
Oui, il donne les relevés. Mais vous
croyez qu'ils vont ouvrir une enquête
sur place pour cerner tous les comptes
de Singapour ? Non, ils répondent au
compte goutte. Alors qu'à Genève, ils
font pas ça. À Genève, ils font
l'enquête. C'est que quand il voit de
l'argent dans une banque de Genève,
Genève est un exemple pour moi, quand il
voit de l'argent dans une banque et que
ça va dans une autre banque de Genève,
ils vont poursuivre les investigations,
vont vous faire une vraie enquête. Ils
vont vous dire voilà l'argent il est
passé Singapour non Singapour ils vous
répondent voilà voilà tel compte et puis
vous allez au bout de 6 mois 6 mois 8
mois vous allez apprendre que le compte
que l'argent il passait systématiquement
à chaque fois qu'il y a de l'argent qui
arrivait sur le compte A il allait sur
un compte B dans la même banque donc
faut que je refasse une demande. Alors
pensez bien que face à un réseau
organisé qui passe par 10 comptes
bancaires dans 10 dans 10 places
financières différentes.
Moi, je veux bien faire de l'archéologie
judiciaire,
mais arrive un moment,
bah le le temps joue contre moi et
quelquefois on n'y arrive pas, il y a
d'autres fois on y arrive parce que le
but et ça c'est nouveau dans la dans la
culture judiciaire, en tout cas ça
n'existait pas avant en France, ça a
fini par rentrer dans les mœurs. c'est
que maintenant on va saisir l'argent. Et
les grands défis aujourd'hui dans ces
enquêtes, alors des enquêtes qui portent
pas sur de la fraude fiscale, qui
portent sur des escroqueries, des
escroqueries TVA, des des affaires de
corruption, des affaires de trafic de
drogue et cetera. On vise la saisie des
fonds et c'est extrêmement difficile et
très aléatoire. C'est la saisie ou la
confiscation ? C'est que ça disparaît
dans les les finances de l'État ou c'est
séquestré ? C'est saisi dans un premier
temps. Il faut que le juge de
l'instruction arrive à identifier le
compte où il y a encore l'argent parce
qu'il a le temps de filer entre-temps
parce que comme il faut des mois, des
années et si par chance on arrive à
identifier de l'argent qui est là, on
demande la saisie. C'estàd que c'est un
blocage.
Mais moi en tant que juge d'instruction,
je peux pas confisquer. J'ai pas ce
pouvoir
qui là
le tribunal plus tard. Donc je demande
la saisie. J'ai obtenu une fois une
saisie à Singapour. Je peux vous dire
que
de combien ? De combien ?
Ouais plus. Il y avait
2500 €. Non non, il y avait entre 15 et
20 millions de dollars autant que je me
souvienne. C'était quand même une somme
importante. Mais rien que pour leur
expliquer euh que je demandais la
saisie, alors on me demande qui vous
êtes. Bah je suis juge d'instruction. Ah
oui, mais on connaît pas le juge
d'instruction à Singapour. Nous, on
connaît que le procureur, il faut un il
faut une décision d'une cour.
Mais je dis je peux pas donner, j'ai ce
pouvoir, je peux même si je voulais
demander à une courge, on me dirait mais
il est fou, il est tombé sur la tête
parce que mon système est complètement
différent. Donc ils ont fini par
accepter euh parce que à force
d'insister, mais ça a pris des mois, euh
la saisie en dit, je leur expliquer mais
un jour peut-être vous aurez une
décision d'une cour d'un tribunal qui
lui ordonnera la confiscation parce que
au stade de l'enquête, au stade de
l'instruction, on poursuit, on cherche,
on trouve. Bon, mais après une fois
qu'on termine le dossier, s'il y a des
charges suffisantes, on renvoie devant
un tribunal et seul le tribunal pourra
ordonner la confiscation
au bénéfice de l'État.
Oui, au bénéfice de l'État. Sachant que
les saisies à l'étranger,
elles sont partagées entre l'État qui va
exécuter en l'occurrence Singapour,
ça peut les intéresser et et la le pays
qui demande. Voilà. Après, c'est ça se
joue entre état.
Jeis qu'on parle des architectes, des
concepteurs de ces circuits,
ceux qui mettent le bitume bien lisse et
bien droit pour pouvoir se accélérer sur
ce type de voie. Je voudrais qu'on parle
du profil et je voudrais ensuite qu'on
parle de quand vous arrivez à attraper
le propriétaire d'un compte et que vous
arrivez à l'avoir devant vous pour le
questionner,
le profil, comment ça se passe ? Comment
vous menz un interrogatoire ? Est-ce que
vous travaillez avec les services
fiscaux ? Est-ce que les services
fiscaux sont suffisamment charpenter ?
Est-ce qu'on leur donne suffisamment de
moyens pour aller chasser et chasser au
gros calibre ? [grognement] Comment ça
se passe ? Alors les les le le juge
d'instruction, il travaille avec des
enquêteurs qui sont spécialisés peut
aussi travailler avec des douanes. Les
les douanes les douanes ça marche bien
hein.
Lo douanes judiciaire, voilà qui peuvent
avoir des renseignements parce que toute
la difficulté c'est d'être renseigné,
c'est de savoir qu'il y a un compte qui
se balade à Singapour. C'est le plus
dur. Une fois que vous avez identifié un
premier compte, vous tirez un fil et ça
c'est au juge, c'est au juges de le
faire. Donc il va falloir identifier ses
avoirs avec le but de de de les saisir.
C'estàd ils ont circulé donc il y a tout
un travail que le que le juge que le
juge doit faire. J'ai perdu le fil de la
question pardon. C'était
les concepteurs. Ensuite
les concepteurs. Je vais vous expliquer,
je vous donne un exemple.
Fraud fraude à la TVA.
J'ai un jour un monsieur qui va qui a
expliqué le process et qu'il a
d'ailleurs il a été jugé, il a répété en
audience publique du tribunal. C'est
pour ça que je peux en parler.
Comment s'est fait la fraude à la TVA ?
La fraude à la TVA,
vous avez un
vous avez un téléphone portable.
J'en ai un. Bon, je sais pas combien il
vaut. Imaginez qu'il vaille 500 €.
C'est plus 1000. Non. Ouais, enfin il
est il est pas tout neuf le mien
et puis je vais le garder parce que je
veux pas je veux pas rajouter à la à la
comment dire à la à la pollution au
carbone machin et cetera. Bon, imaginons
qu'il va 1000 € euh TVA
200 € ou
donc moi je vais l'acheter 1000 €
et les 200 € de TVA ils vont normalement
pour l'État seulement imaginez que ça
soit Bouig ou je ne sais qui qui soit le
fournisseur de ce téléphone mais il va
acheter des téléphones alors en quantité
oui d'autres
d'autres oui sion si on pas de nom mais
beaucoup vont vont acheter Mais non,
mais de bonne foi, ils vont acheter des
téléphones à l'étranger
en quantité importante. Et parmi ces
fournisseurs ou ces sous-fournisseurs en
amont, vous avez des petits malins qui
vont vendre des téléphones hors TVA, qui
vont pardon qui vont acheter ces
téléphones hors TVA et qui vont les
vendre TVA incluse. Bon, je le fais
courte parce que je veux pas être
compliqué mais ils vont prendre au
passage les 20 % de TVA. C'estàd que sur
les 1000 € que j'aurais payé sur mon
téléphone, il y a 800 pour ceux qui ont
fabriqué le téléphone et 200 non pas
pour l'État mais pour les fraudeurs. Et
ces fraudeurs, ils ont mis l'argent à
Hong Kong. Attend avec des multiples
sociétés et cetera. C'est compliqué.
Mais c'est ça la fronde à la TV. On
appelle ça de l'escroquerie parce que
ces gens-là récupèrent les 200 € de TVA
et qui est laisé une fois de plus
l'état, la collectivité qui est prévé de
ressources. Ça c'est vous et moi. Voilà
exactement. J'aurais préféré payer 800
plutôt que de donner 200 à des à des
fraudeurs.
Donc les concepteurs, comment ça se
passe à l'interrogatoire ? les les
profils de de
alors d'abord quand vous avez un réseau
de de fraude à la TVA euh le concepteur
faut le trouver
je dirais le commanditaire
les doues vous aident et les services
fiscaux vous êtes ça
oui ils m'aident bien sûr qu'il m'aident
parce que ils ont beaucoup de
renseignement et ils sont ils nous sont
extrêmement utiles et en plus nous on
communique aussi he c'est parfaitement
c'est parfaitement légal mais
vous donner l'exemple alors frod la TVA,
il va à Hong Kong, d'accord ? il va Hong
Kong et il emmène quelqu'un qui l'a
croisé dans un bar le soir qui a besoin
d'argent et il dit voilà
si tu veux tu me prêtes ta carte
d'identité au mieux on va on va aller
ensemble à Hong Kong
euh et tu me prêteras tes papiers sur
place
je te donnerai 1000 € et puis on on
voilà donc l'autre accepte alors faut
quand même quelqu'un qui soit un peu un
peu présenté able qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire Kong ? Ils vont à Hong Kong et à
Hong Kong ils vont dans ce qu'on appelle
j'allais dire une fiducière
une structure où on vend des sociétés
clé en main, des sociétés des British
Virgin Island. Je sais pas si tu les
British Virgin Island toujours beau
là-bas,
il fait toujours beau. On est sous les
cocotiers mais on fournit aussi des
sociétés à ces sociétés de conseil qui
sont basées à Hong Kong.
Et donc là, il va avec son gérant, celui
qui va devenir le gérant qui qui vit qui
a du mal à payer son loyer, qui est au
chômage et cetera et qui lui va gagner
1000 € en espèce qui pour lui est
important. Puis en plus, il va avoir de
jours 2 jours de voyage tout frais payé
à Hong Kong. Et donc là, il va acheter
une société des British Virginia, je dis
bien à Hong Kong, c'est là qu'on marche
sur la tête parce qu'on est dans la
fiction totale et il va dire voilà c'est
une société pour pour le monsieur qui
m'accompagne qui est le gérant de la
société. Donc ils vont sortir de là, ils
vont avoir une société offshore, une
société écran, une société bidon avec
pour gérant celui qui accompagne.
Le lendemain, qu'est-ce qu'ils font ?
Vous savez que pour un circuit offshore,
faut des sociétés mais faut faut aussi
un compte bancaire.
Bah, ils vont aller chez HSBC,
chez un autre
ou chez un autre starter,
chez un autre si vous voulez.
Et là, ils vont se présenter à la banque
en disant voilà, moi je veux faire du
commerce avec la Chine, je suis dans le
vêtement, je suis dans c, je suis dans
ça ou dans l'informatique. Euh, je
voudrais ouvrir un compte, j'ai une
société et là dans la banque, on va leur
ouvrir un compte au nom
de la société des British Virgin
Islands, dont le gérant sera l'homme de
paille, celui qui est recruté pour ça.
Je peux je peux vous déconcentrer une
seconde ?
Ben allez-y.
La banque en question qui a pignon sur
eu, elle se pose pas question,
elle se pose aucune question
et en plus elle va par la suite, il va y
avoir des fonds qui vont arriver sur le
compte.
On va ouvrir, ils vont aussi ouvrir un
deuxième compte dans une autre banque au
nom de la même société. Et moi j'ai vu
des comptes où tous les jours il arrive
50000 € 100000 € et aussitôt ça repart.
C'est ce qu'on appelle des comptes de
passage. N'importe quel banquierah
lucide va se dire "Mais à quoi ça
correspond ?" On voit bien que c'est des
comptes de passage. En France, vous avez
un organisme qui s'appelle Tracfin. Je
veux dire, si et si vous faites pas la
déclaration à tracfin, vous allez vous
faire taper sur les doigts et on va les
poursuivre. La justice fera son travail.
Et ben Hong Kong, non,
on fait pas. Pourtant, Hong Kong avait
affiché des tasses forces. Je suis allé
une fois en réunion à l'OCDE, ils
étaient là en disant voilà nous on lutte
contre le blanchiment, on lutte et là
ils font rien. Et en plus ils vont
recevoir par la suite des demandes des
juges d'instruction qui vont enquêter.
Vous croyez qu'ils ouvraient une enquête
et qui poursuivraient les les
responsables ? Non. Voilà. Et là on voit
la tolérance de ces pays à l'égard de
ces process. On est quand même dans
l'escroquerie à la TBA, ils le savent,
on leur dit, on leur écrit. Alors, je
reviens à mon à mon gérant là parce que
qui vient avec euh
son homme de paille,
avec son homme de paille. Alors, c'est
l'homme de paille qui va être le gérant.
C'est le seul qui va apparaître.
D'ailleurs, un jour, quand les impôts
vont remonter la filière, ils vont bah
oui, ils vont tomber sur le sur le gars
qui arrive pas à payer son loyer tous
les mois et il va apprendre qu'il y a
des dizaines de millions d'euros qui
sont passés sur son compte à Hong Kong.
Donc il va tomber de l'armoire.
Évidemment, on est complètement à côté
de la plaque. Moi, j'ai toujours dit aux
enquêteurs quand après j'ai reconstitué
un peu la chaîne, je écoutez moi les
gérants, je veux pas en entendre parler.
Il faut identifier les commanditaires.
Alors celui qui va sur place, qui est un
recruteur de gérant qui sait faire parce
qu'il parle anglais tout ça, il connaît
bien le process des offshore, il va
quand il va sortir de la banque, la
banque va remettre
au gérant, l'homme de paille, un alors
moi je je suis nul en informatique,
un espèce de token qui permet à distance
de faire des op Vous connaissez
qui peuvent faire à distance des
opérations en générant des codes
informatiques sécurisés.
Alors évidemment le gérant de paille
quand il sort, il va remettre le token à
l'autre et et en l'occurrence l'autre
quand il rentre, il a un commanditaire,
il va lui remettre le le token et ce
commanditaire, il va pouvoir faire des
opérations à distance sur de multiples
comptes. Alors ce ce recruteur de géants
expliquait aussi que quelquefois il
allait avec trois gérants.
trois gérants, ça veut dire trois
sociétés qu'on a qu' achetait sur place
six combes bancaires.
Donc celui commanditaire, il avait toute
une voilà c'est ça un système offshore
et qui il est impossible à identifier
puisqu'il n'apparaît pas. Les seuls qui
apparaissent sont les gérants. Donc
c'est un peu comme la mafia, non ?
Oui, c'est pareil. C'est pareil. Et
d'ailleurs, il y a des mafieux qui ont
recours au même au même système. Et
c'est très difficile après quand vous
enquiétez parce que vous allez tomber
sur les vous savez, on tombe sur les
petits, OK, on va tomber sur les sur le
petit gérant de base mais il nous
intéresse pas. Ce qui nous intéresse,
c'est qui l' recruté, comment et cetera.
Et là, c'est des enquêtes qui sont
extrêmement compliquées.
Alors, ces enquêtes là, est-ce que
maintenant vous utilisez un peu plus la
technologie, c'est-à-dire
les caméras de vidéos surveillance, les
écoutes téléphoniques,
les pistages, le traçage ?
Attendez,
à la banque pays, c'est ça.
Vous croyez qu'à Hong Kong ils
enregistrent, ils filment et ils vont
vous donner le les gens qui sont rentrés
? Mais vous avez déjà demandé ?
Bah non, je l'ai pas demandé mais rien à
rien.
Oui, c'est vrai, vous avez raison. Mais
je veux dire déjà, je vais vous dire
quand on m'a dit Hong Kong euh j'avais
dit aux enquêteurs j'y vais pas.
C'est non, j'y vais pas parce que Non,
mais j'y vais pas physiquement, mais je
je bouge pas parce que j'en ai pour des
années et ils vont me mener en bateau et
cetera. Bon, parce que l'argent avant
d'aller à Hong Kong, il était aussi
passé à Chypre, il était passé dans les
pays Baltes et cetera. Donc, j'ai
commencé par travailler sur ces pays-là
qui pays baltes.
Euh, alors je confonds toujours là,
c'est la Lonie. De mémoire, c'est la
Léonie ou l'Estonie, je les confonds.
Mais ils ils ouvraient des comptes comme
ça euh avec même même chose des comptes
de blanchiment, des des comptes qui
servent à blanchir de l'argent. Ils ils
travaillent beaucoup avec les Russes. On
est dans l'exosphère soviétique et il y
a des mauvaises habitudes qui ont
continué. Et c'est vrai que dans un
deuxième temps, les enquêteurs sont
venus en me disant qu'une fois que
j'avais fait mes demandes au Pays-Balt à
Chypre, ah oui mais tout l'argent repart
à Hong Kong parce que tout repartait.
Donc je me suis dit OK je je vais y
aller enfin je pas je vais pas y aller
physiquement, je vais envoyer des
demandes mais je sais que mon dossier
j'en ai pour des années et des années
avec un résultat extrêmement aléatoire.
Bon, c'est j'ai hte à le dire. Je crois
que j'ai j'ai mis 7 ans à traiter ce
dossier. Euh bon, voilà, c'est mais on a
j'ai réussi à récupérer une partie de
l'argent et encore pas tout l'argent
parce que j'ai perdu la trace quelque
part.
Donc vous avez pas eu le commanditaire
dans la fraude de carbone ? Si.
Expliquez-nous ça comment. Et vous avez
réussi à le convoquer ? Oui, il a même
été incarcéré
dans dans la dans les alors je peux pas
parler d'une affaire précise que j'ai
instruite mais je dire dans ces affaires
de fraude carbone euh il y a eu cette
huit juges d'instruction au pôle
financier qui ont été saisis un peu
d'une façon dispersée. Après, on a
croisé les informations et de nombreux
commanditaires ont fini par être
identifiés,
arrêté, ce qui a pas été facile parce
que certains étaient en Israël, Israël
leur avait accordé la nationalité donc
ils voulaient pas les extrader. Mais
malgré tout, il y a eu il y a eu des
peines de prison lourdes qui ont été
prononcées. Par contre, si on fait le
bilan de l'argent parce qu'on parle
d'unard 400 millions, il cite la cour
des comptes 5 milliards en Europe,
on en a pas récupéré le tiers ou le
quart
et l'argent est pas perdu pour tout le
monde.
Je veux bien qu'il y a des frais, qu'il
a de l'évaporation, qu' a des grands
trains de vie. OK, mais voilà et au bout
de d'années et d'années d'enquête. Donc
vous voyez à travers cet exemple que
c'est très dur de reconst encore il y a
fallu
passer beaucoup de temps d'énergie sur
un dossier pour essayer de retrouver les
vrais euh qui n'apparaissaient jamais
nulle part. Donc c'est c'est ça que je
voulais expliquer. Je voulais dire voilà
ces circuits offshore ils existent.
Ces outils, ils sont utilisés par ces
fraudeurs mais ils sont aussi utilisés
par des fraudeurs fiscaux. Euh il y a il
y a toute une gape de de gens qui qui
masquent qui cachent leur argent. Il
aussi la la corruption.
Il y a il y a pas mal de dictatures euh
dans ce monde hein. Euh et les
dictateurs, bah il ils cachent leur
argent avec des prêtons. Alors souvent
c'est des amis, c'est des hommes
d'affaires et ils ouvrent des comptes
comme ça au nom de société offshore où
ils n'apparaissent jamais. Ça peut être
aussi des proches, ça peut être les
enfants, ça peut être euh la femme. Euh
on on a vu, j'ai vu l'exemple d'un
oligarque aussi parce que on trace
aussi, on essaie aussi de tracer
l'argent des oligarques mais ils passent
dans les mêmes circuits. Donc euh Bercy
a les pires difficultés à Ber et les
autres les autres pays ont les pires
difficultés à reconstituer ces circuits.
Quand vous discutez avec les
fonctionnaires de Berill, euh quand vous
discutez avec les douiniers
à bâton rompu,
ils vous disent quoi ? Ils vous disent
"J'y gagne 3000 balles par mois,
j'essaie d'aller chercher des millions à
gauche et à droite.
H
on est sous-dimensionné,
on n pas assez de charpente. Le pouvoir
politique à gauche et à droite, bon nous
aide pas trop. Il y a pas un phénomène
de démotivation ou c'est ça qui les
motive ? C'est quoi ? C'est l'intérêt
général, c'est d'aller à la chasse la
piste. C'est c'est quoi ?
Je dirais que c'est l'intérêt général,
c'est-à-dire
c'est jamais complètement perdu
d'avance. Si vous si vous considérez que
c'est pas la peine, bon qu' vous assurez
l'impunité totale, autant rendre son
tablier tout de suite.
Si vous persévérez, d'accord, vous aurez
un taux d'échec mais quelquefois vous
arriverez à faire bouger un peu les
lignes. Voilà. Et je crois que dans
notre monde euh il faut les faire bouger
les lignes. Et ben oui, parce que euh il
y a
ça a pas l'air de bouger beaucoup là
hein.
Ça il y a il y a quand même des avancées
euh qui sont faites au niveau de l'OCDE,
euh des échanges de données
d'information euh euh entre pays, mais
vous savez, plus on avance, plus les
circuits sont sophistiqués et je dirais
qu'à chaque fois les fraudeurs, ils ont
un coup d'avance. Donc c'est c'est
extrêmement compliqué. Et en plus, c'est
les les offshores, elles bougent. Là, je
vous parlais de Hong Kong il y a
quelques années. Aujourd'hui, je suis
pas sûr que
que les grandes fortunes aillent à Hong
Kong, sachant que le grand frère chinois
est pas loin. Bon, je veux bien que les
Chinois corrompus cachent leur argent à
Hong Kong ou ailleurs. Aujourd'hui, je
dirais que Singapour se frotte les mains
et puis vous avez l'émergence de de
nouvelles places. Le Liban est était
aussi une placeée.
Ouais. Bon, Chypre l'a été,
elle ne l'a plus été. Il semble qu'elle
le redevienne pour les oligarques. Bon
et puis vous avez des pays comme Dubaï
aujourd'hui qui prospèrent sur l'argent.
Euh vous avez euh des pays comme l'île
Maurice, les Séchelles où il y a il y a
beaucoup d'argent qui qui circulent
parce que les Frodur aujourd'hui essaie
de de trouver des endroits euh où ils
soient à l'abri. Et alors je vous dirais
qu'en plus vous avez vous avez vu il y a
les papers, il y a les
c'est ces fameuses fuites d'information.
Voilà ces fuites d'information
qui ont nécessairement des lanceurs
d'alerte à l'origine et ces informations
qui vont être traitées par des grands
des grands journaux, des grands médias
qui vont analyser et qui vont publier
des listes.
Il y a eu par exemple les Dubaï Papers,
il y a eu les Panama Papers,
tout ça dans une période récente, ce qui
prouve que le phénomène perdure.
Et je me dis à chaque fois que je vois
des parutions, je me dis finalement
ils sont pas à l'abri
d'un lanceur d'alerte
d'un fuite.
C'est fuites
ou de de de bons hackurs.
Oui, ça peut être des hackurs, ça peut
être aussi des informaticien de
l'intérieur. On nen sait rien. Alors, il
y a les lanceurs d'alerte qui
apparaissent directement et puis il y a
cette nouvelle technique de lanceur
d'alerte qui passe par la presse parce
que la presse, elle est libre, elle a le
Bah, en tout cas, il y a des il y a des
médias qui le sont. Bon, me demandez pas
de faire le procès de la presse, je me
permettrai pas. Mais vous avez des
médias qui sont
Vous auriez envie
comment
de faire le procès de la presse ?
Non, non, non. parce que dans ce dans le
cas que que qui m'intéresse, la presse
agit dans l'intérêt collectif et de
façon désintéressé et
disclose
et et tout ça, la CG,
le monde, le Guardian, voilà, le New
York Times, le Sud Saung en Allemagne,
ils analysent chacun leurs propres
nationaux en quelque sorte et il ils
agissent collectivement, ils exploitent
des des milliers de de données alors
qu'ils ont par ces hackeurs ou par ces
ces informaticiens
parce que malgré tout à chaque fois même
si vous faites une opération à Hong Kong
avec votre token à distance, il y a
toujours une trace informatique.
Tout passe par une une ligne
informatique. Sauf si vous si vous allez
chercher les espèces. OK, mais les
espèces ça va jusqu'à 50 100000 €.
au-delà ça ça va les ça va être visible,
faut les ramener, faut donc les grands
fondeurs eux ils agissent comme ça
masqués à travers des circuits offshore
et à travers des virements informatiques
qui laissent toujours une trace. C'est
comme ça qui que les les informaticiens
qui ont accès à un fichier
d'une banque ou d'un d'une fiducière
vont vont y avoir accès, vont réussir à
décrypter
dans les circonstances que bon que
j'ignore. En tout cas, quand il passe
par la presse, il bénéficie du secret
des sources puisque personne ne peut
identifier les sources, c'est la liberté
de la presse et c'est important. Donc
vous avez comme ça des masses
d'informations qui sont qui sont
révélées et qui créent euh chez les
fraudeurs de l'insécurité.
C'est peut-être d'ailleurs pour ça que
les hommes politiques préfèrent les
valises de cache, non ? Parce que c'est
plus difficile à aller les chercher.
C'est il y a que les chiens qui peuvent
le le pérer ou un contrôle inopiné des
douanes sur un quai
de gare, c'est ça ? Oui, mais je vais
vous dire les valises de Cach
le le l'ancien dictateur du Nigéria à
Bacha dont vous avez dû entendre parler.
Il paraît que quand ils sont allés chez
lui à sa mort euh ils ont trouvé plein
de plein de billets. Bon
mais le plus gros était pas là. Le plus
gros il était en Suisse et il était en
Angleterre.
En Suisse, les Suisses ont fait un
travail parce qu'il y a eu une plainte
du successeur de de ce de ce dictateur
et ils ont recouvr quand même des
centaines de millions de de francs
suisse. On parlait de milliards de
dollars au départin
et il y a une partie de l'argent qui est
parti en Grande-Bretagne, en Angleterre
et là les Anglais n'ont rien fait, il y
a pas eu de saisie. Euh donc l'argent
est parti, il est pas perdu pour tout le
monde. Donc euh le cash, Oui, mais le
cash euh vous pouvez pas transporter euh
100 millions d'euros, c'est pas
possible. Trop de risque.
Surtout en billet de
Puis il faut les avoir. Bah attendez, en
billet de 500, qu'est-ce que Comment
vous allez écouler ?
Ouais. Ouais.
Vous avez des billets de 500 ? Moi je
alors alors faudra en commander à la
banque. Mais pourquoi ? Picop.
Vous parliez des lanceurs d'alerte. Euh
en France, on a eu Stéphanie Gibau euh
qui qui nous a donné quelques
informations et qui a donné quelques
informations au fisque. Euh ça a permis
au fisque français de récupérer un peu
de pognon.
Elle est au moins que le RMI, ça fait 10
ans. Elle vient à peine d'être connue
comme lanceur lanceuse d'alerte.
Est-ce qu'il faut les rémunérer ces
lanceurs d'alerte ? Est-ce qu'il faut
que l'État dise voilà si nous on peut
récupérer tant bah vous avez tant de
pourcent ? Je crois qu'aux États-Unis
ils font comme ça non ?
Oui tout à fait. Ils le font aux
États-Unis dans l'affaire de l'UBS aux
États-Unis. Le lanceur d'alerte, je
crois qu'il a il a gagné 100 millions de
dollars mais il en a fait gagner je sais
pas combien au au fisque américain.
Vous savez, ils ont aussi la culture du
shérif qui va mettre qui va offrir de
l'argent à qui arrête quelqu'un et
cetera.
Est-ce qu'il faut le faire ? Je
En tout cas, on doit les protéger
ces lanceurs d'alerte. Les rémunérer
comment ? Je ne sais pas.
On doit les protéger. Je dois vous dire
qu'en en Europe, il y a des lanceurs
d'alerte qui non seulement n'ont pas été
protégés, mais qui ont été poursuivis
par la Suisse, euh par le Luxembourg
pour violation du secret bancaire,
atteinte au secret bancaire.
Et ces pays préfèrent
préférait
bah c'est pas si vieux que ça. Regardez
au Luxembourg, il y a eu des
condamnations. Il y a encore Oui, ils
hésitent maintenant parce que derrière
vous avez la presse qui est derrière qui
va dénoncer leur comportement mais il y
a il y en a un en Suisse qui a été
incarcéré comme ça pendant plusieurs
mois en Espagne. Bon donc sûrement
d'arrêt des des Suisses. Pourquoi ?
parce que ces pays
veulent affirmer la primauté du secret
bancaire. Peu importe ce que ça cache,
il y a une violation du secret bancaire
par quelqu'un de l'intérieur, un
informaticien et cetera. Il a détourné
donc les banques déposes plaines et ce
sont eux qui se retrouvent poursuivis.
Alors qu'aux États-Unis,
non seulement ils sont pas poursuivis,
en plus les Américains ont obtenu dans
l'affaire du LBS la liste des clients.
Parce que si vous la donnez pas,
si vous banque vous donnez pas la liste,
qu'est-ce qui va se passer ? Bah est-ce
que vous allez pouvoir faire continuer à
faire des opérations aux États-Unis ?
Est-ce que vous allez pouvoir faire des
opérations dollars ? Si vous pouvez
plus, vous êtes morts, vous n'existez
plus.
dans l'affaire HSBC qui a eu à la même
époque en France, pas seulement en
France d'ailleurs parce qu'il il avait
des des fichiers des copies de fichiers
qui ont qui ont alimenté d'autres
d'autres pays où on a découvert beaucoup
de beaucoup de fraudes où il y a eu des
sommes importantes et bien ils ont
refusé de coopérer.
Ils ont refusé de coopérer au motif que
les fichiers étaient volés. Donc il y a
deux poids de mesure.
Et sur cette fameuse copie de fichier,
est-ce que des fois il y a des copies de
fichier trafiqué ?
Mais oui, ça peut ça peut. Donc il faut
toujours comparer à l'original. Mais si
le pays, en l'occurrence la Suisse
refuse de vous donner l'original au
motif que mais non, c'est un fichier
volé, on refuse, on va poursuivre celui
qui vous a donné les fichiers,
c'est compliqué,
ça facilite pas le travail. Est-ce que
dans vos listes, est-ce que dans vos
listes ou est-ce que vous avez vu
certaines listes ou certaines fuites de
Panama Papers, de Papers, de machin,
est-ce que vous avez vu des noms de
leaders politiques européens ?
Ben, ils en ont sorti. Alors, j'ai pas
j'ai pas toutes les listes.
Euh oui, il y en a il y en a eu mais je
je pas en tête le contenu le nom des
personnes. Il y a il y a des hommes
politiques, il y a aussi des des gens du
showbiz, il y a enfin des gens qui ont
beaucoup d'argent et qui le cachent.
Voilà. Euh et puis il y a aussi les
trafiquants de drogue. Il y a de tout.
Voilà.
Quand vous arrivez en serré hein,
pas serré.
Bah lui pass
c'est vous qui employez le terme de
serrer.
Moi je sers pas. Instruit.
Je cherche à comprendre.
Bon
quand vous arrivez à le faire venir avec
des pinces d'accord
la pince pince
à la cheville. La pince
accompagné voulait dire.
Voilà. Merci. Je chercher le mot
d'ailleurs.
Bien entouré.
Euh le profil en face que est-ce que
pourquoi il fraude ? C'est juste pour en
avoir plus, toujours plus.
C'est parce que ils sont égoïstes ?
C'est parce que quoi ?
Moi je ne lis pas dans leur dans leur
pensée.
Il y a la pas du gain évidemment
quand quand vous quand vous économisez,
si j'ose dire un ou 2 millions d'impôts,
bah vous les gagnez, vous les avez en
plus, vous les vous les payez pas à la
collectivité. Donc il y a encore une
fois il y a aussi des des escrocs. Donc
là tout l'argent est détourné et il
masque il masque tout. Euh comme je
disais, il y a il y a de tout. Donc
voilà, je pense que c'est surtout la pas
du gain évidemment.
Alors question internet.
Comment voit-il la frontière entre
évasion fiscale et optimisation fiscale
? A-t-il des suggestions pour faire
évoluer la législation dans ce domaine ?
Hm. Euh pour moi,
l'évasion fiscale,
c'est à peu près la même chose que
l'optimisation fiscale.
C'est-à-dire que c'est le moyen euh
notamment pour des multinationales
euh [grognement] de pas payer d'impôt.
les gafas et autres qui
les GAFA par exemple on le sait quand
ils vont quand ils opère en France ou en
Allemagne ils vont pas mettre leur siège
en France ou en Allemagne ils vont
mettre leur siège européen en Irlande ou
à Îldoman ou je ne sais où dans des pays
au Pays-Bas même au Luxembourg dans des
pays où ils feront remonter les
bénéfices
sachant qu'ils peront beaucoup moins
d'impôts que s'ils laissaient leurs
bénéfices dans le pays. Oui, où il
travaille
mais c'est légal,
c'est apparemment légal.
Si c'est apparemment, c'est que c'est
légal.
C'est légal mais ça le devient de moins
en moins. Parce que où est la frontière
entre l'évasion et la fraude fiscale ?
C'est une question de perception ou une
question de loi ?
C'est Oui, il y a une question de loi
mais c'est vous savez des lois
internationales, il y en a pas. Donc euh
bah
il y a quand même les lois pour le
commerce, pour la guerre.
Oui mais oui mais qui va vous poursuivre
? Un état Bery ou un ou le parquet
national financier ou des juges
d'instruction d'un état.
Il faut que dans la législation ça soit
considéré comme de la fraude. Et il y a
une évolution actuellement mais qui
est pas complètement faite et à mon avis
il faut aller plus loin qui consiste à
dire
vous par exemple
vous omettez de déclarer euh 10000 € sur
votre feuille d'impôt.
C'est pas possible,
on a une expert comptable.
Elle nous laisse pas faire ça.
Oui, mais tout le monde n'a pas un
expert comptable.
Écoutez, il y a quand même aussi de la
France brasse parce qu'elle va nous
regarder ce soir et on
Oui, mais par exemple, vous savez les
maintenant les la plupart des employeur
déclare les revenus des personnes mais
pas toujours. Donc si vous avez pas une
démarche positive, je sais pas moi si
vous si vous des revenus fonciers que
vous les déclarez pas, ça peut ça peut
passer à travers. Si vous déclarez pas
tout
consciemment, volontairement.
Oui, bien sûr. C'est une mission, on va
vous dire fraude fiscale.
Je suis une multinationale.
Je vais voir 10 conseillers fiscaux qui
vont me dire "Vous avez des revenus là,
mais on va faire des conventions à
trappe pour faire remonter les bénéfices
de la du pays où on paye des impôts vers
un pays où on paye beaucoup moins
d'impôts."
Légal.
apparemment légal parce que il y a tout
un montage, il y a tout un stratagème
et c'est là la limite parce que comment
pouvez-vous dire qu'une mission c'est de
la fraude fiscale et que des montages
qui sont fait parfaitement siamment et
qui n'ont d'autres but que pas payer
l'impôt ? Vous allez dire là c'est
légal.
Vous achetez un avion, un jet déjà vous
allez polluer jet privé, vous polluez.
Excusez-moi de le dire mais bon, vous
allez me dire "Oui, je dis ça parce que
je circule pas en jet." OK, d'accord
mais ça pollue énormément.
Vous aimerez bien hein quand même.
Ah, j'adorerais étrange même pas
imaginer.
Mais
petite coupe de champ.
J'aimerais bien aussi ne pas payer la
TVA lorsque j'achète mon jet. Comment je
fais ? Bah, il y a des conseillers qui
vont me dire "On va créer une société à
l'îdoman
et on va vous faire tout un montage et
vous éluderez la TVA."
Un yach, j'aimerais bien avoir un yach
de 50 ou 60 millions. On va faire un
montage à
petite casquette. Je vous verrais bien
avec la petite casquette. [rires]
Je serais que celui qui va dessus
pendant les vacances, mais j'aurais rien
à mon nom là. Je peux vous dire que là,
je sais faire comment comment
n'apparaître nulle part. Peut-être que
je vous déclarerai d'ailleurs comme
bénéficiaire. Vous m'adoptez, [rires]
c'est ça ?
Voilà, je vous prendrai votre carte
d'identité, on se débrouillera. Mais
voilà, donc les ya, c'est pareil. Il y a
des il y a ce qu'on appelle les leasings
maltais. Vous allez à mal, vous créez
fictivement une cé de leasing et vous
allez dire c'est de l'évasion fiscale,
c'est pas de la fraude fiscale. Je ne
suis pas du tout d'accord avec ce ce
raisonnement et je souhaite qu'on qu'on
évolue vers de la fraude parce que je
trouve que c'est la même chose, c'est
même pire. Donc et ça porte sur des
sommes qui sont qui sont énormes. Voilà.
Alors avant de dire c'est légal pour
répondre à la question de de
l'internaute
qui est une excellente question, je
dirais que l'évasion, l'optimisation
c'est celui qui achète son ya qui achète
voilà qui ou la multinationale qui va
implanter son siège en Irlande et faire
remonter ses bénéfices par une
convention ingroupe. Là on est dans
l'évasion, dans l'optimisation et c'est
vrai que la les avocats vont vous dire
c'est parfaitement légal. Bon, c'est
discuté pour les raisons que je viens de
vous indiquer. À côté de ça, vous avez
la fraude fiscale. Monsieur, vous n'avez
pas déclaré l'intégralité de vos
revenus. C'est de la fraude fiscale.
Vous avez perçu sur un vous êtes
dirigeant de l'international dans une
dans une entreprise importante sur un
contrat international. l'intermédiaire
vous aersé 500000 € sur un compte à
Chypre, c'est de la fraude fiscale et en
plus c'est du détournement de de c'est
de l'abonce, c'est le détournement de
bien de la société dont vous n'êtes que
le que le salarié ou le mandataire si
vous êtes directeur général.
C'est combien de tôles ça ? Si
les textes prévoient 50 prisons
et et avec ou sans aménagement ? Bien
sûr, il y a toujours des aménagements.
Bah comme toute personne, toute personne
condamnée et c'est normal à droit des
aménagements.
Si j'ai des problèmes de santé euh
euh vous savez, vous avez des remises de
peine lorsque vous vous comportez bien
en prison, que vous faites des efforts
de réinsertion et cetera. Donc alors les
peines ont tendance à on passe souvent à
10 ans parce qu'on passe par du
blanchiment aggravé, pardonnez-moi la
technique mais voilà les peines quelques
je parlais de la fraude de carbone tout
à l'heure était sont quand même tombé à
8 ans euh 9 ans
donc 5
combien ils exécutent je je suis capable
de vous dire mais ils n'exécuteront pas
les 8 ans s'ils se tiennent bien en
prison bien sûr
et et est-ce que c'est suffisamment
dissuasif parce que Si si
alors je vais vous dire si vous faites
ça aux États-Unis
c'est 150 ans de prison là tout de suite
ça
c'est 150 ans de prison. Bon parce qu'on
c les peines, on a on les additionne. En
France on raisonne pas comme ça.
Après si vous voulez c'est la
l'appréciation c'est la loi qui le dit.
Les juges appliquent la loi point barre
hein. Moi, je n'ai fait qu'appliquer la
loi toute ma vie. Et encore, je ne
prononçais pas les peines. Je
j'instruisais pour essayer d'éclairer et
de présenter un dossier qui se tient
devant un tribunal en disant voilà
j'identifie tel commanditaire et cetera
et je fais une démonstration parce que
la plupart du temps les faits sont niés.
Euh les les gens n'apparaissent pas donc
il y a d'autres éléments qui vont
révéler que
Et comment ça se cuisine ? On cuisine
pas, on cuisine pas euh le le
on assaisonne.
Non, on interroge les personnes, on leur
pose des questions, ils ont le droit de
pas répondre, ils ont droit au silence
et ils ont le droit de vous mentir.
Même pas un petit coup d'annuaire
derrière les oreilles, il y a rien.
Non, ça c'est c'est dans les c'est dans
les films que vous voyez ça.
Ripou contre Ripou, c'était pas mal.
Oui, mais on n'est pas des Ripou.
l'état de droit, la personne est
assistée d'un avocat, ils ont accès au
dossier, en tout cas devant le devant le
juge d'instruction. Et je dirais que ce
qui est important, c'est enfin pour moi,
c'était d'instruire, je dirais à la
loyale, c'estàdire soit vous avez
la possibilité de faire une
démonstration et vous mettez la personne
face aux éléments dont vous disposez et
vous l'écoutez parce que vous pouvez
vous tromper. Il y a des éléments qui
peuvent se révéler très contestables. Il
peut les retourner.
Soit il va pas s'expliquer ou il va
fournir des explications, mais vous
allez les vérifier, vous apercevoir que
la personne a menti, vous allez
l'expliquer tout ça. Donc on est sur un
terrain, je dirais de c'est la
rationalité qui doit qui doit
l'emporter. C'est l'état de droit.
Voilà. Et si et si vous arrivez à faire
la démonstration et ben après on il
s'expliquera dans le tribunal qui lui
appréciera les peines.
Alors j'ai fait une blague avec Ripou
contre Ripou et le le coup de la
lumière. C'est en fait pour pouvoir me
lancer sur mon autre question.
À force de regarder dans les ténèbres
de ces montages,
de voir les jets privés, les
les yachotes, les belles pépé, les
belles montres, tout ça, est-ce que ça
vous
retourne pas le cerveau ? Est-ce que ça
vous aviez eu envie un jour de basculer
dans ce genre de truc ? Est-ce qu'on
vous a proposé un peu de pognon ? Est-ce
même pas ?
Non, parce que je pense que c'était
quand même risqué de le faire.
Connaissant la réponse.
C'est combien la gramais fait ? On a
jamais fait.
C'est 5 ou 10 ans. Attention. Et puis
c'est pour le juge aussi hein.
Attention. [rires]
Non. Euh
à force de regarder dans les ténèbres,
on devient pas un peu sombre ?
Non.
Non. Non.
Pas du tout. Pourquoi voulez-vous ?
Après, chacun a sa vie. Chacun
si vous avez de quoi vivre, vous avez
pas besoin de de compte cachés de de
choses comme ça. Pourquoi avoir des
comptes cachés pourquoi avoir des trusts
? Euh il y a des gens qui ont des
trusts.
Il faut expliquer ce que c'est un trust.
Un trust, c'est c'est comme une société,
si vous voulez dans lequel vous allez
loger tous vos avoirs.
Quand je parle vos avoirs, c'est 100
millions, 20 millions, 30 millions, 100
millions. Bon, à un moment donné, vous
allez tout donner à un trust. C'estàd
que les les biens ne vous appartiennent
plus. C'est de la purfiction, c'est un
concept anglo-saxon.
Euh et dans ces trusts, bah par exemple,
vous allez mettre des des œuvres d'art
qui valent des fortunes et vous allez à
travers le trust les léguer à vos
enfants
ou à la belle-mère.
Oui. Ou à condition d'elle grand-mère.
Voilà. À condition à condition d'avoir
l'esprit de famille. Tout le monde n'a
pas l'esprit de famille. Donc voilà.
Donc,
j'ai souvent eu ces discussions sur les
trusts où des avocats me disaient "C'est
légal, c'est [grognement] angloaxon,
c'est légal. Qu'est-ce que vous avez
contre les trusts ?" Bah oui, mais euh
moi si j'achète une villa
argenteuil
Oui. Alors, d'accord, j'achèterai pas
une villa à 10 ou 20 millions d'euros.
OK. Et là effectivement,
bon mais j'ai pas besoin de trust. J'ai
pas besoin de trust si je veux léguer
des biens à mes enfants. J'ai pas besoin
de trust. Pourquoi votre client
éprouve-t-il besoin le besoin de créer
un trust ?
Mais vous vous rendez pas compte,
monsieur le juge, les l'impôts sur les
successions, c'est un scandale. J'ai
travaillé toute ma vie pour fournir une
rentre à mes à mes enfants.
Oui. D'accord. Et vos enfants, qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont fait pour obtenir tout ça ?
C'est simplement
Ah bah oui, mais
quel est
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce travail là ?
Quel est quel est le mérite en quelque
sorte de celui qui hérite d'énormément
d'argent comme ça qui n'est pas qui
n'est pas taxé ? Euh bon,
à un certain stade, ça ça ne se justifie
plus à mon avis. Euh maintenant,
il y a des droits de succession. Bah
payer les droits de succession. Si si
vous transmettez 100 100 millions, vous
avez je sais pas 30 millions, bah vous
les payez puis c'est tout.
Si vous reste 70 comme ça, bah c'est
déjà pas mal.
Pourquoi vouloir en plus échapper ?
Parce que c'est ça le raisonnement.
C'estàd que arrive s'installe, plus on
échappe mieux c'est et plus on en a plus
on va échapper grâce à ces montage.
Comment vous percevez ceux qui disent en
anglais taxe is is the fraud ? C'est le
fait de taxer les gens c'est une fraude.
On ne pas payer les taxes parce que
voilà c'est c'est d'accord. Et payer les
hôpitaux, c'est de la fraude. Payer le
la transition climatique, c'est de la
fraude.
Payer votre salaire de juge.
Payer mon salaire, c'est de la fraude.
Allez-y. Bah oui, bah c'est votre
vision, c'est pas la mienne.
Non, c'est pas ma vision.
Non, c'est la vision de ces gens-là.
Voilà. Voilà ces arguments là. Une fois,
j'avais un un ambassadeur du Lenstein
qui m'a dit dans la discussion comme ça
informelle euh "Oui, mais parce que il y
avait de l'argent caché au Lenstein."
Donc je dis "Bah oui, mais c'est
peut-être pas tout à fait normal." dit
"Oui, mais vous taxez trop en France."
Bah oui, si vous taxiez moins, il y
aurait il y aurait pas d'argent ou moins
d'argent. Donc finalement,
on a une soupape comme vous dites, une
soupape qui est qui est utile utile pour
tout le monde. Oui, mais attendez,
monsieur, si vous allez à l'hôpital,
vous êtes gravement malade, vous croyez
que c'est à Vanus qu'on va vous soigner.
Si vous mettez vos enfants à
l'université
gratuite comme c'est le cas en France,
qui va payer ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il a répendu ?
Il a il a il a considéré que j'étais
vraiment un taxateur pas loin pas loin.
[rires]
Dialogue de sour
vous l'aviez convoqué ?
Non non pas du tout. C'est une
conversation informelle que j'ai eu
comme ça. Vous
étiez retrouvé dans la même pièce dans
le même métro. Vous étiez dans le même
métro comme ça avec le pas dans le même
métro mais euh
non.
Il y avait d'autres personnes de ce
genre de ce calibre là dans la pièce
dans le même métro dans le même vagon.
D'abord c'était pas dans le métro. Ça
doit être je cit pas à Bruxelles ou
ailleurs, je sais plus. J'ai j'ai Ça
remonte à à 10 15 ans. Ouais mais ça va
vous savez les J'ai pas de mémoire.
Vous avez appris à force de faire des
interrogatoires que la mémoire sélective
c'est bien. Non,
elle est très sélective.
L'amnésie sélective.
Très sélective l'amnésie. Oui. Oui. Vous
pouvez me parler quelquefois de telle
affaire, de telle société, je vais m'en
souvenir. Mais voyez là où je l'ai
rencontré, je me souviens plus.
Je suis désolé.
Par contre, je me souviens très bien de
ce qu'il m'a dit.
La transparence
quand on on voit que les États renoncent
à faire la transparence
de ce qui est fait dans les boîtes,
ça vous fait quoi ?
Alors, de quoi vous parlez là ?
transparence dans les boîtes.
C'estàd que on peut plus avoir accès à
la comptabilité des boîtes, c'est le
secret des affaires, c'est le secret de
du secret bancaire, c'est le secret du
secret. C'est
alors si si vous si on parle des paradis
fiscaux, c'est le sujet, il y a des
secrets bancaires très forts.
C'est-à-dire que c'est tout le problème,
c'est que on considère que le secret
bancaire fait partie de la protection
dont toute personne a le droit légitime
de de elle peut légitimement bénéficier.
Voilà. Et tant qu'on aura ce plus ce
secret bancaire va être fort, plus euh
plus vous aurez de fraude. Évidemment,
maintenant que votre voisin est pas
accès à votre compte bancaire, ça ne me
choque pas. Euh
moi, je distinguerais la collectivité,
euh l'État qui est représenté par bah
des juges, des procureurs, des
inspecteurs des impôts et cetera qui eux
doivent avoir accès aux informations.
Mais que les que les particuliers est
accès à ces mêmes informations, ça c'est
pas possible.
Moi, je comprends qu'il y a une
protection. Voilà, c'est un autre sujet.
Euh on n'est pas dans la transparence
totale. On pourrait l'être, on l'est
pas.
Ça me gêne pas ça. Ça ne me gêne pas. Ce
qui me gêne, c'est que quand on a un
compte à Dubaï,
ni les juges d'instruction, ni les ni
ber ne pourront avoir accès aux
informations. Ils auront juste pas de
réponse. Ça ça me gêne.
Question internet de DD.
Que fait Bery concrètement selon
monsieur Vrunbec pour récupérer l'argent
qui devrait être déclaré ? Comment
pensent-ils que les citoyens puissent
contrôler le travail de Bercy ? Bah de
Bery, c'est que il a le même problème
que les juges. C'estàd que comment
voulez-vous qu'il sache que quelqu'un a
100 millions à Singapour ?
S'ils savent pas, qu'est-ce que vous
voulez qu'il fassent ? Vous aurez
multiplié les effectifs, vous saurez
pas.
Alors si un jour ils ont une
information, bah ils vont la traiter
bien sûr, mais ils vont se au même
problème que les juges. C'estàd bah oui,
il faut obtenir le compte de Singapour,
c'est une société offshore et cetera,
c'est des circuits. Enfin, vous
connaissez la chanson.
Question d'internet.
En parlant de Bery, on l'arrête quand le
verrou de Bercy ?
Le le verou de Bery, il est quand même
il a quand même été affaibli le verou de
Beri. C'estàd que dans les grandes fres
moi je vous savez on parle du
verrouille. C'est quoi le verrou ? C'est
le fait de garder le contrôle du de la
poursuite des fraudes. Voilà. Euh j'ose
[grognement] croire quand même que quand
il y a des grandes fraudes et que Mercy
est bloqué, soit il négocie avec la
personne, pourquoi pas ? Soit en taxant
par exemple à 40 50 %, je ne sais pas,
tout dépend de la nature de l'affaire et
si les personnes ne veulent pas, ils
transmettent à la justice. Ça me paraît
le fonctionnement normal.
Donc si j'ai bien compris, c'est une
petite négo quoi non ?
Bah il y a une négociation avec les
fraudeurs fiscaux.
Pourquoi on négocie avec les fraudeurs ?
Parce que il y a de l'argent quelquefois
qui est gagné sur du travail.
Simplement, il est pas déclaré, il est
pas fiscalisé. Si vous éludez, je sais
pas 30 % d'impôt, on vous taxe par
exemple
petit joueur, petit joueur.
Oui. Bah peut-être petit joueur, mais
vous êtes vous d'abord est-ce que c'est
vous qui venez spontanément ou est-ce
que c'est Mercy qui vous a identifié ?
même pas du tout la se pose pas dans les
mêmes termes parce que celui qui vient
spontanément
on aura tendance à pas trop le taxer et
on taxera plus un avec un plus bien sûr
je suis pas dans le secret de Mercy,
j'en sais rien. C'est eux qui qui font
ça. Mais celui qui se fait prendre à son
insulte plein grré si j'allais le dire
lui on va le taxer beaucoup plus
ce qui est normal.
Bah oui ce qui est normal.
Euh question d'internet. Bonsoir à la
team. Le futur de l'évasion fiscale
selon lui a-t-il malheureusement un
avenir radieux ou est-ce que les États
vertueux ont suffisamment de puissance
et d'outil pour lutter contre ? Son
expérience de juge donne-t-il une once
d'espoir ?
Oui, bien sûr. Bien sûr, parce que je
crois à la prise de conscience.
Ben oui. Euh bah oui, mais c'est comme
le climat. Tout
ce qui vous
Mais c'est comme le climat. Alors, vous
pensez qu'on va tous Bah, c'est comme le
climat. Vous pensez qu'un jour on va
tous étouffer ? Bah
on est bien parti, on par CO2,
on est bien parti quand même. Non,
je pense qu'il y aura une réaction à un
moment donné. Oui, mais il a ré Non mais
vous savez euh paniquer pendant que le
train déraille, ça change pas grand
chose, hein.
Oui, mais enfin le jour où vous pouvez
plus respirer, euh vous prenez peut-être
les mesures qu'il faut prendre,
c'est-à-dire aller chercher.
Vous attendez pas de ne plus Vous
attendez pas de ne pas pouvoir de ne
plus pouvoir respirer.
Bah là, ça dépend, c'est un peu
l'histoire de la grenouille dans la
d'eau chaude. Vous savez, alors je vais
vous dire déjà, il y a l'histoire des
oligarques.
Les oligarques, on va geler les avoirs
des oligarques. On n'y arrive pas. On y
arrive que d'une façon minime. Est-ce
qu'on va supporter ça éternellement ?
Deuxièmement, il y a les déficits des
États. Vous avez rappelé au tout début
ces déficits, jusqu'où ils vont aller ?
Est-ce que les États vont être si un
jour les États peuvent plus payer et
qu'il y a de l'argent à côté, ils iront
peut-être chercher l'argent. Donc il
Moi, je pense qu'on est dans un monde
qui bouge.
Oui, il peut se passer des événements.
Regardez la guerre en Ukraine, personne
n'avait prévu.
Comment j'ai pendant lu
la guerre ? Je dis la guerre en Ukraine,
l'agression de la Russie quand même bien
la poudre quand même. Non, personne l'
parce que la Russie
ceux qui ont pas travaillé, ils l'ont
pas prévu. Bah
écoutez ça, c'était quand même une
surprise de voir la Russie encore
aujourd'hui attaquer l'Ukraine. Enfin,
une guerre en Europe, c'est c'est enfin
pour moi, c'est pas une surprise pour
tout le monde en tous les cas. Comment
c'était pas une surprise pour tout le
monde ?
Oh pour beaucoup de gens quand même. Et
je veux dire c'est c'est des événements
qui peuvent faire bouger les choses
parce que vous voyez de là on dit il
faut saisir les oligarques. Si on
s'aperçoit qu'on peut pas parce que
Dubaï coopère pas parce que si parce que
ça on va peut-être commencer à à bouger
à réagir. Il peut se passer d'autres
événements. Il se passera d'autres
événements.
Je suis convaincu moi que la génération
qui vient derrière elle résoudra
nécessairement le problème parce qu'on
peut le résoudre. Et si elle le résout
pas et qu'il y a une continuité dans la
captation de la richesse et du pouvoir,
hm.
On va vers quel type de moi je
je suis pas un prédicateur, hein. Je moi
je constate simplement, je sais pas ce
qui se passera demain, je fais le
constat.
Point de vue, vous avez bien une petite
idée.
Je sais pas de quoi de quoi demain sera
fait. Honnêtement, j'en sais rien.
Vous parliez des oligarques en général,
ils sont bien méchants. Ils ont accès à
des mafieux, à des tueurs à gage. Vous
avez déjà été sous protection policière
?
Oui, une fois.
Combien de temps ?
3 semaines.
Avec combien de personnes ?
J'avais deux deux gardes du corps qui
m'accompagnaient, venaient me chercher
chez moi.
Et votre famille était sous protection
aussi ?
Non,
il y a Mais
elle était à l'écart. On l'avait mise à
l'écart
dans une adresse qu'on connaissait pas.
Oui, voilà.
C'était à la suite de quoi ?
Les malaces. De qui ?
De gens qui voulaient 10 ans me tirer
dessus. C'était il y a il y a 25 ans et
les policiers.
Moi, j'ai
reçu des menaces mais je suis pas
C'est des menaces quoi. C'était une
lettre écrite avec en l'occurrence c'est
quelqu'un qui s'était répandu dans une
salle de rédaction en disant qu'il y
avait un contrat sur moi, qu'il était
qu'il avait été coopté mais qui
dénonçait parce que bon, il y avait eu
une chambre d'hôtel qui avait été
réservé. Effectivement, un hôtel qui se
trouvait près de de l'endroit où je
travaillais à l'époque à Renne. La PJ a
vérifié.
Donc ils m'ont dit "Ou là là, prenez les
choses au sérieux." Bon moi j'y croyais
pas trop mais bon.
Et finalement au bout de 15 jours, ils
m'ont dit "Bon on arrive pas, ils sont
pas venus,
on pense que c'est de la toxe et
cetera." Donc je dis "Bon stop, vous me
laissez vivre tranquillement." Voilà,
c'est c'est l'épisode que j'ai connu.
Vous avez un permis de port d'armes ?
Non.
Vous faites un sport de défense ?
Vous avez jamais pensé à savoir tirer
avec un pétard ? Ben, j'ai appris à
l'armée pendant mon service militaire,
mais ça remonte, ça remonte, ça remonte,
ça remonte à
euh alors 60, c'est pas grave hein,
la mémoire qui
74 Voilà 74 mais ça marque he le service
militaire.
Vous êtes pour vous êtes pour le retour
du service militaire ? Écoutez, je l'ai
très mal vécu.
On se demande bien pourquoi. [rires]
Je l'ai très mal vécu. Euh mais je
reconnais que ça avait un mérite, c'est
que tout le monde était mélangé.
On se retrouvait à 30 là dans une
section euh pauvre, pas pauvre et
cetera. Alors évidemment, il y en a qui
échappaient puis qui étaient pistonnés.
Bon, mais il y a il y a ce brassage euh
et le fait aussi de
vous avez le sentiment de perdre votre
temps, mais parce que vous travaillez
pour la collectivité
à une époque 74, il y avait plus de
menace, il y avait plus de Donc voilà,
je l'ai fait.
De toute façon, j'avais pas le choix.
Euh puis j'en ai profité pour faire du
sport. Ça m'a fait pas fait de mal pour
ça. J'ai découvert un peu tout ça. J'ai
le manque de liberté quand même parce
que quand vous êtes à l'armée, d'autres
décident pour vous de tout hein, de
votre emploi du temps de tout. Donc faut
l'accepter. Voilà,
faut parler de perte de liberté.
L'erreur judiciaire
envoyer quelqu'un au placard pendant des
années alors que vous vous rendez compte
après qu'il était pas coupable.
Ça vous est déjà arrivé ? Oui. Non.
Est-ce que c'est arrivé à vos copains ?
Est-ce que vous connaissez des dossiers
? Est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça fait ?
C'est c'est une angoisse qu'on doit
avoir. C'està dire que quand alors vous
savez qu'un juge d'instruction ne peut
plus mettre en prison aujourd'hui, il
doit toujours solliciter un juge
extérieur qui lui va apprécier s'il faut
mettre en prison ou pas. Donc il a plus
ce pouvoir. Les juges l'avaient jusque
dans les années 2000.
Mais même là quand vous prenez la
responsabilité de saisir un juge pour
dire voilà j'estime que
faut toujours faire très attention.
Alors moi la détention c'est quelque
chose que
je n'aime pas par définition. Voyez si
on peut l'éviter, on va tout faire pour
l'éviter. Il y a certains cas, on peut
pas faire autrement. En matière
criminelle par exemple, en matière
financière,
on va l'appliquer lorsque la personne
est en fuite à l'étranger, qu'on arrive
à l'arrêter. Évidemment qu'on va pas la
la libérer comme ça tout de suite.
Après, ça peut se régler sous forme de
caution et cetera, mais il faut vraiment
des garanties des garanties sérieuses.
Pour moi, la détention n'a jamais été un
but en soi. La sanction non. Euh,
j'étais confronté à des à l'instruction
de dossiers qui était difficile, qui
était compliqué et le vrai enjeu pour
moi c'était d'arriver à démonter euh ce
qui se passait en prenant des garanties
pour que les personnes se sauvent pas,
mais en amenant le dossier
correctement instruit, en ayant vérifié
toutes les fermé toutes les portes qui
pouvaient y avoir de façon à ce qu'on
puisse pas dire dans le tribunal "Ah
mais le juge, il a pas vérifié ça ou il
est parti sur cette hypothèse qui était
fausse." Donc toujours de vérifier et
l'angoisse euh de se tromper parce que
le doute euh c'est fondamental, on peut
se tromper, on a des intuitions mais on
peut avoir des bonnes comme des
mauvaises intuitions. Donc c'est ça le
l'angoisse du juge d'instruction.
Toujours être habité du doute
bien sûr et toujours écouter l'autre.
Quoi qu'on puisse penser,
il a une part de vérité. Ils peuvent
vous expliquer des choses qui vont faire
tomber votre dossier ou qui vont faire
tomber certains aspects du dossier parce
que vous êtes laissé embarquer. Donc
l'écoute des personnes, des enquêteurs,
des avocats, des personnes poursuivies,
des victimes. Il faut que le juge écoute
tout ça et qu'il essaie de comprendre et
de rationaliser un petit peu les choses
pour pour que pour construire son
dossier. Quel regard vous vous portez
sur le système carcéral français ? La
surpopulation. Euh
Ben, il y a une surpopulation. Euh,
c'est évident. Euh
et donc et donc est-ce que la sanction
n'est pas plus contre-productive
qu'autre chose ? Et comment vous jugez
les pays qui reconvertissent leur prison
en hôtel de luxe ? parce que il y a plus
il y a plus assez de méchants à mettre
dans les prisons.
Mais là, vous avez une vision très très
caricaturale des chose.
C'est fait exprès.
Oui, je m'en doutais. Je vous vois
venir.
[rires]
Alors, je vais essayer de dans les
choses moins moins caricaturales.
Il y a de plus en plus de gens en
prison.
Les la société est de plus en plus
répressive. On construit de plus en plus
de prison.
Oui, on en construit.
Elles sont surpeuplées. La question qui
se pose, première question,
est-ce qu'il est légitime de mettre
autant de gens en prison aujourd'hui,
c'est d'en mettre plus qu'avant ? Et
pourquoi ? Alors, il y a des gens qui
méritent d'être en prison et il doit y
avoir des sanctions très lourdes contre
certains agissements. On est tous
d'accord là-dessus. Mais il y a aussi
beaucoup de petites moyennes délinquence
pour laquelle j'entends souvent oui, les
juges mettent pas en prison.
il relâche et cetera. Et quand vous avez
un petit camp qui a un passé qui est pas
évident, euh qui a un père délinquant,
qui a une mère alcoolique, qui a Vous
croyez que si vous le mettez en prison,
euh qu'est-ce que vous allez en faire ?
il va rencontrer d'autres personnes plus
si c'est un jeune qui ont plus
d'expérience que lui et quand il va
sortir si vous faites rien bah il
recommencera et vous en ferez un
délinquant un multirécidiviste. C'est
pour ça qu'il y a quand même des lois en
France qui prévoient la réinsertion
et pour réinsérer les gens il faut les
aider. Il faut des éducateurs. Euh mais
oui euh vous savez
il y a qu'à bon
faon.
Oui. Bah j'ai présidé les assises il y a
très longtemps
et il y a des jurés des jurés. Alors moi
je trouve ça très bien les jurés parce
que c'est le peuple qui juge. Voilà. Et
quand ils sont face à leur
responsabilité
et qu'ils entendent les explications des
avocats, des personnes, c'est plus il y
a qu'à c'est plus du tout ça. Ça les
interpelle et c'est ça la justice.
Il y a pas que des que des méchants, que
des il y a il y a cette vision un peu
caricaturale. Il y a qu'à tous les
mettre en prison. OK, d'accord. Vous les
mettez tous en prison et après vous
allez construire d'autres prisons, vous
allez ils vont recommencer, vous allez
vous allez il faut à un moment donné
essayer de de dégonfler tout ça et de
prévoir tout un travail de rééducation,
d'accompagnement. Quand quand vous un
détenu qui est libéré au bout de 3 ans
de prison, vous croyez qu'il va il va se
réinsérer comme ça tout seul ? Il peut
pas. Il faut l'accompagner, il faut lui
accorder des permis sur sortie, il faut
qu' voilà, il y a des libérations
conditionnelles, enfin, il y a des
mesures qui sont prises. Vous allez dire
quelqu'un qui est condamné à 5 ans, il
va pas faire 5 ans. Bah oui, parce qu'au
bout de 3 ans, on va commencer à l'aider
à s'en sortir, à reconstruire quelque
chose. Le but, c'est quand même, une
fois qu'il a payé sa dette en quelque
sorte envers la société qu'il puisse
qu'il puisse repartir. Si vous
considérez qu'il faut juste le punir, le
mettre en prison, bah OK, bah vous
fabriquez de la délinquence et vous
aurez jamais assez de prison.
Quel regard vous portez sur la la
perpétuité et quel regard vous portez
sur la rééducation du des terroristes ?
Est-ce que il y a des gens, ils sont
tellement perdus pour la société qu' on
peut plus les les rejeter ? Je
sais pas mais je sais pas. Alors
là, vous sortez complètement de mon
domaine parce que j'ai jamais vu de
perpétuité en matière financière [rires]
à part les 150 ans de Madof.
Euh la cybercriminalité, ça vous parle ?
Vous voulez qu'on rentre dedans ou bof ?
J'ai pas beaucoup traité ce sujet.
D'accord. Euh
je suis un vieux hein. Je suis pas
Oh ouais, vous avez pas si vieux que ça
quand même.
Bref,
alors parlons de Dubaï, le cas des
influenceurs à Dubaï.
Le cas des influenceurs.
Ouais. Ouais. De du genre un peu beauté.
Vous en avez entendu parler ou pas ?
De quoi ? des influenceurs.
Ouais. Quand Bruno Lomè est sorti en
disant "Bon alors les arnaques machin,
vous étiez à Dubaï, racontez-nous un peu
tout ça."
Non
non. Est-ce que vous avez un sujet que
vous voulez aborder avec nous et notre
communauté ? Est-ce que vous voulez
parler d'un truc qui vous tient à cœur
et qui vous tient à quelque chose ?
Non, moi ce que j'ai voulu euh euh à
travers ce livre, c'est justement
expliquer aux gens qui nous écoutent euh
une réalité, ce que j'ai fait un peu
avec vous, en essayant d'être le plus
le plus clair possible, j'espère que je
l'ai été, pour expliquer comment ça
marche parce que ce sont des montages
qui sont compliqués. Je vous en ai
expliqué un un un petit peu. J'espère
que vous m'avez suivi. Je pas trop
rentrer dans la technique, mais euh
c'est pour que moi il me paraît
important euh que les gens sachent
comment ça marche, ce qui se passe, la
réalité des choses. Après, ils en font
ce qu'ils veulent.
Alors, je vous pose une question entre
les deux.
Ouais.
Question d'internet.
Que pense l'invité du manque de du
manque grandissant d'exemplarité des
politiques ? De point détournement de
fond. Arrêtez de me faire remonter la
ligne. Détournement de fond, emploi
fictif prise égale d'intérêt. Il
faudrait faudrait-il des conditions de
casier vierge et des et des
inéligibilités
automatiques.
Alors moi je vais vous dire les
pas de politique.
Oui déjà voilà. Vous avez anticipé, vous
avez lu dans ma pensée. Bravo. Mais je
suis contre les peines automatiques
parce que pour avoir été juge, pour
avoir siégé parfois en correctionnel ou
ou aux assises, euh ce qui compte c'est
la liberté
d'appréciation
du juge.
C'est quoi ? C'est ce qui fait
l'humanité d'une société. C'est la
qualité de ces juges.
Oui. Oui. Oui. Voilà. Vous vous lisez
dans mes pensées, c'est bien, on va
finir par se comprendre. Je pense qu'on
s'est déjà compris.
Oui, je pense aussi largement. Mais euh
c'est vous savez vous dire "Ah, il a il
a fait si vous avez un dossier, il a
fait si il vient, vous l'avez devant
vous." Ah oui, mais attention voilà son
passé, voilà les circonstances, vous
l'écoutez.
Vous faites quoi ? Euh, j'ai ma liberté
en tant que juge. Je suis pas tout seul.
En général, on est trois parce que c'est
des c'est des décisions très lourdes
pour les personnes qu'on a à juger. Mais
il faut cette liberté parce que si vous
dites il a ça fait trois fois qu'il
commet un vol donc c'est automatiquement
5 ans. Vous apercevez que depuis parce
que il s'est écoulé un certain temps bah
il est réinséré, il a trouvé un travail
et cetera. Vous avez quoi ? Vous avez
cassé tout un toute une reconstruction.
Donc faut laisser la liberté au juges de
d'apprécier. C'est pour ça que toutes
les peines automatiques, je suis
absolument contre.
Et quand la société se radicalise,
est-ce qu'il faut que nous nos juges se
radicalisent aussi ?
Non. Non. Les les juges doivent garder
leur humanité et doit doivent toujours
garder une distance. Alors évidemment,
on est sensible à ce qui peut se passer
dans un quartier et cetera évidemment,
mais on doit pas être
vous savez, je l'ai vu avec les médias,
euh on doit pas être comment dire, on
doit toujours mettre de la distance tant
que possible. C'estàd qu' on doit
essayer d'être juste, d'être juste.
C'est c'est compliqué parce que bon, il
y a les de côtés de la balance, vous
savez, c'est très difficile la justice.
C'est pas Yaka.
Donc question faucon.
Quand on voit le manque de moyens de la
justice, a-t-il des craintes pour le
moyen terme sur les dégradations des
conditions de travail des juges ? Et
j'en profite pour balancer une autre une
autre question.
La récidive chez les frudeurs fiscaux,
elle est élevée ?
Bah déjà pour être récidiviste quand
vous êtesur fiscal, faudrait déjà que
vous soyez attrapé une fois. Un
récidiviste, c'est quelqu'un qui a déjà
été condamné. Si vous prenez les
fraudeurs fiscaux euh qui ont leur
argent en Suisse ou ailleurs, ils ont
jamais été condamnés. Donc ils sont pas
récidivistes au regard de la loi.
Sur le manque de moyens de la justice.
Bah je crois que tout le monde a la
conscience aujourd'hui.
Euh il y a aussi il y a pas que les
moyens euh
prenant la matière que je connais un
peu, c'est la matière financière. Vous
décidez demain de doubler le nombre de
juges, d'instruction, d'enquêteurs et
cetera.
De prison
de PR. D'accord.
Euh, vous réglez pas le problème de
Singapour.
Il faut peut-être doubler notre budget
de l'armée, aller envahir Singapour
direct.
Vous avez peut-être pas besoin d'envoyer
l'armée pour mettre Singapour au pas.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour mettre
Singapour au pas ? Bah, faudrait que les
pays qui sont spoliers euh décident un
jour d'assurer des règles de
transparence à Singapour, à Hong Kong,
aux Ilaillement, à Chypre et cetera.
Pourquoi on le fait pas ? Il faut
parce que c'est parce que c'est
compliqué d'abord. Ensuite, c'est comme
le c'est comme l'environnement, c'est
pareil. Il faut une volonté
internationale
forte euh qu'il y a pas. Euh il faut une
prise de conscience. Je crois que ça
passe par une prise de conscience du
citoyen. Le jour où le citoyen considera
que c'est c'est un sujet important, les
politiques commenceront à à bouger. Mais
c'est pas c'est pas à l'échelon de la
France qu'on va régler le problème.
Évidemment, c'est tout le problème.
Toute la difficulté est là.
La France c'est un paradis fiscal pour
les autres ou pas ?
Non, pas du tout.
Pas pour les Cataris qui investissent en
France ou des choses comme ça. Non. Ah
bah après qu' y a des accords fiscaux
avec certains États parce qu'ils
investissent chez nous, c'est une chose.
Mais ça c'est oui, je vois ce que je
voulais dire.
Question d'internet. Que pensent-il du
fait d'engager d'anciens criminels pour
arriver à traquer les nouveaux ? Il y a
rien de mieux qu'un voleur pour attraper
des voleurs.
D'accord. Mais ce monsieur qui a fraudé
à Singapour, est-ce qu'il connaît le
compte de son voisin ?
Moi, je crois plus au lanceur d'alerte
qui va qui va vous donner des
informations et que vous allez traiter.
Alors, question provoque.
Il faut que j'arrive jusqu'à la fin.
Ah, question provoque. Je pense que
c'est une question provoque. Je suis
étonné qu'il ne soulève toujours pas la
nécessité du bagne comme outil de lutte
contre la corruption et la fraude.
A-t-il un avis sur l'exemplarité des
peines pour faire réfléchir les autres ?
Moi, je crois que les la meilleure c'est
pas une question de bagne, c'est la
question d'identifier les l'argent. Le
jour où celui qui a de l'argent à
Singapour se dira ça va se savoir, j'ai
900 sur 10 d'être prix, il viendra payer
ses impôts. Tant qu'il a une chance sur
100 d'être pris, il viendra pas, quelle
que soit la peine. Mais s'il a neuf
chances, s'il a 9 chances sur 10 d' prix
et d' plus de recevoir des coups de
bâton en plein cagnard.
Oui, mais c'est pas ça la justice. On
est dans les états de droit. Je
le ba il y a longtemps. Bah oui, mais
poser la question.
C'est ça.
Question d'internet très courte mais pas
pas dénué de sens. D'où vient l'absence
de volonté ?
C'est que les les les populations qui
doivent s'emparer du sujet ou les
politiques aussi ferment un œil ou
tournent la tête ou
je crois qu'ils savent pas faire.
Il y a il y a un problème de comment
régler ce problème
sachant que alors on pourrait prendre
des initiatives en Europe déjà puisqu'on
fait partie de l'Union européenne,
bouger, mobiliser les autres pays
européens pour déjà faire le mêlage en
Europe, imposer à Chypre des règles de
transparence et pas se contenter de ce
qu'ils vous disent.
Voilà, c'est c'est toute cette dynamique
là qui n'existe. Il y a pas de
dynamique, voyez, on pourrait imaginer
une COPE fiscale par exemple comme vous
avez la COP 27 et cetera pour faire le
point pour dire bah voilà la fraude
fiscale c'est temps dans le monde, c'est
ça c'est temps dans ces pays-là et
mettre les ces pays au pied du mur. Il y
a il y a qu'une démarche comme ça qui
peut faire bouger les choses.
Toujours question internet.
Le me faites pas sauter les lignes les
gars. [grognement]
Le consentement à l'impôt en France
pilier de la coopération des citoyens.
Quand on voit le inégalités de
traitement de tout ça, le consentement à
l'impôt, on fait comment pour le faire
passer ?
Ben, on devrait lutter contre cette
fraude fiscale internationale de façon
beaucoup plus efficace
justement pour pour que chacun parce que
vous gagnez de l'argent, c'est normal de
payer des impôts
quel que soit votre niveau,
sauf si vous avez des petits revenus
bien sûr, mais
c'est tellement
vous vous bénéficiez des routes, vous
bénéficiez des écoles, vous bénéficiez
des hôpitaux, la gratuité. Donc il est
normal que chacun côtise. Ce qui est pas
normal, c'est que certains y échappent.
Bien sûr. Et c'est pas pour ça tout le
monde doit s'arrêter de payer ses
impôts. La cryptoonnaie, ça vous fait
peur ?
Alors, j'ai vu rent Oui, parce que j'ai
vu récemment qu'il y a une des une des
je sais plus laquelle qui est tombée là
euh dans des circonstances d'ailleurs
qui sont pas très très clairs. Donc
du pognon qui est parti à gauche à
droite, on sait pas où quoi.
Je demande à voir parce qu'il y a pas de
contrôle par définition. On sait aussi
que ça a pu servir à des blanchisseurs
l'argent justement de de cette fraude.
Dans quelle proportion ? J'en sais rien.
J'ai pas j'ai pas enquêté sur la
cryptoonnaie. Euh mais évidemment, il y
a un risque important.
Est-ce que vous avez trois conseils ?
Non. Trois bouquins et un conseil pour
les jeunes générations.
Pourquoi trois bouquins ?
Parce que j'ai envie de trois bouquins.
Bah moi je vous donne je vous donne bah
je vous donne le mien. Ça c'est interdit
ça. [rires]
Trois bouquins qui suffit pas.
Trois trois bouquins qui ont compté dans
votre vie,
qui vous ont fait grandir, qui vous ont
fait qui ont construit votre
raisonnement, construit votre
personnalité qui ou qui vous ont fait
voyager,
qui vous ont transcendé,
qui vous ont fait vibrer ou peut-être
vriller.
Là, c'est très personnel. Ça a rien plus
rien à voir avec la la justice, avec
notre sujet.
Ben ouais. Pourquoi vous voulez qu'on
continue l'interview ?
Moi, je veux bien mais j'adoré Socrate
Platon.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que
Socrate n'a pas de de vérité.
il amène l'autre devant sa contradiction
pas uniquement par le dialogue.
Et ça c'est une démarche
qu'on a jamais dépassé.
Je j'attendrai la suite du titre des
bouquins. Comment voulez-vous un jour
que les politiques votent des lois de
contrôle des paradis fiscaux s'ils
viennent et repartent travailler dans
les banques ou pour les multinationales
?
Vous pouvez travailler dans des banques
ou des multinationales sans faire des
montages dans des paradis fiscaux ? Bah
j'aime bien vous l'entendre dire parce
que l'activité bancaire c'est pas que
ça.
Mais bien sûr mais j'irais même dans les
multinationales. J' même dans les prenez
prenez la Suisse par exemple. Si vous
prenez la Suisse, toute l'ingénierie
qu'il y a en Suisse de banque et cetera,
la majeure partie des opérations, c'est
des opérations qui sont qui sont
transparentes, qui sont qui sont pas
contestables. Moi, je vous parle de la
part grise. Voilà. Et il y a aussi cette
part là, mais c'est pas toute l'économie
mondiale. Quand on parle de 8700
milliards, je sais pas combien il y a
d'argent qui circulent dans le monde. Il
y en a beaucoup plus. Donc faut pas tout
réduire à cette part qui est qui est
fraudée. Donc il y a des activités
légitimes des banques, des
multinationales qui sont tout à fait
normal.
Revenons à nos livres.
Oui.
Vous en avez deux titres à nous donner.
Alors
deè livre le livre de la tranquillité.
Ça vous parle Fernando Pessoa
qui je pense c'est le plus grand penseur
du du 20e siècle.
qui est dans le prolongement de cette
pensée socratique qui pose des questions
fondamentales.
Voilà, très grand très grand livre.
Un troisème
après c'est des choses plus
personnelles.
Comment s'appelle déjà votre bouquin
avant ?
Le livre de l'intranquillité de Fernando
Pesso non le votre livre à vous, c'est
quoi le titre ?
Offshore.
Voilà le trè livre. Voilà 3è livre
offshore mais
vous avez pas trouvé un titre plus
intéressant ?
Non, [rires]
il y a marqué quand même les coulisses
édifiantes des paradis fiscaux
quand même.
Oui. En sous-titre.
Alors à
mais si vous êtes pas content du titre,
adressez-vous à mon éditeur. [rires]
C'est quoi le nom de votre éditeur ?
Ah bonne question. Elle elle
les éditions qui délient qui libèrent.
Les liens qui libèrent. Voilà.
[rires]
Me demandez pas ce que ça veut dire
parce que des liens ça attache mais là
c'est des liens qui libèrent.
On vous demandera pas ce que
c'est la question à l'éditeur parce que
là moi je
4e bouquin
4e bouquin je sais pas quoi vous dire
moi. Il y a mais après c'est des
bouquins plus personnels. J'adorais par
exemple dans la littérature russe les
frères Karamazov.
Très grand livre.
Vous l'avez lu en version originale ou
traduite ? J'aurais bien aimé le lire en
russe mais là j'ai mes limites.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations,
une bouteille à la mer.
H
quelque chose qui est dur
de jeter une bouteille à la mer.
Non, avec un conseil dedans quand même
pour les jeunes générations. Bon, une
bouteille en verre recyclable avec un
Mais gardez vos idéaux
que ça c'est plus important. Soyez
fidèles à vos idéaux, les trahissez pas.
Non, ça paraît Oui,
c'est pas mal. C'est pas mal.
Ouais, il y a mieux. Bon, d'accord.
[rires]
Renovant Rbec, merci.
Je vous en prie. C'est moi qui vous
remercie le du temps que vous m'avez
accordé.
C'est toujours un plaisir de vous
recevoir.
Ah bah écoutez, partagez. [rires]
[musique]